okay so I saw this movie a few days ago
and my abdominal muscles are still sore
I'm not even kidding
this is the end is directed by Evan
Goldberg and Seth Rogen it's star Seth
Rogen James Franco Jonah Hill Craig
Robinson Jay Baruchel as well as Danny
McBride Michael Cera and many other
celebrity cameos that I will not spoil
now in this movie all these actors are
actually playing themselves James Franco
plays James Franco Michael Cera plays
Michael Cera they're playing sort of
exaggerated versions of what the public
knows of their persona like for instance
James Franco in this movie just he loves
art so much he has all these artistic
paintings all over his walls and
sculptures throughout his apartment all
these things are very important to him
Jonah Hill plays Jonah Hill but in this
movie he is this extremely nice man who
just wants to be so kind to everyone and
Seth Rogen in this movie is all into
weed and he's just like a laid-back guy
and essentially he's playing exactly the
same when the characters he plays in
other movies which leads me to believe
that he does actually continuously play
a version of himself in other movies but
all these guys are coming together to go
to James Franco's house for a big
celebrity party night when all of a
sudden explosions start to occur and
weird beams come out of the sky and I
don't really want to tell you exactly
what is happening since it is sort of a
plot point in the film that you're not
sure what is going on but if you can
tell from the title of the movie
something involving the end of the world
is taking place so all these guys come
back together - James Franco's house to
try to survive the next few days and my
word this is one of the funniest movies
I have seen in so long this is the end
is truly a hilarious comedy and as I
have said in many reviews I'm kind of a
hard laugh when it comes to movies
because I've seen so many comedies and
when you see like 200 movies in theaters
a year like I do certain movies just
aren't funny anymore that may be funnier
to other people I need something fresh I
need something different
I need something to really strike me as
original and this is the end is all of
those things one of the funniest things
about this movie to me was the idea of
seeing these celebrities portray
themselves and have their own twist on
what they act like that was so funny for
this film and it added something so
playful and original and it really made
it feel like these guys just came
together to make a movie and be friends
kind of like how when I grew up and I
was a teenager I'd come together with
my friends and we make our own little
short films we weren't really trying to
do anything serious but we had an idea
of what we were doing and we just wanted
to have a good time and a lot of those
short films when I go back and i rewatch
them nowadays as an older person they're
not well made but they're really fun to
watch yourself with your friends
interacting and improving and doing
comedy that probably wasn't on paper it
came about just because of your
relationship with each other and I see
that in my older films I made when I was
a teenager I can see that that kind of
quality is extremely hard to harness in
a big film like this but they did it
because you can really feel like these
guys are all buddies and like you know
we're going to make a movie where we
just do a lot of improv we have a
general idea we have certain scripted
scenes but we're going to try to do our
best to use our friendship and our
overall camaraderie as people to make a
movie that really works this movie isn't
just fun comedy that's a lot of really
great horror and action sequences in it
as well I don't want to spoil too much
about the movie but there's a lot of
really great scenes in this movie that
left me very impressed it has a lot of
sophomoric humor and quite a bit of
vulgarity that's for sure
you're gonna go into this movie and
you're gonna hear something and you're
gonna be like wow I can't click they
said that but they did but certain
comedies try to do that where they try
to be vulgar and they think well I'm
just going to say something dirty and
it'll be so funny
it really doesn't work like that that
just comes off as annoying or cheap like
they can't come up with their own
writing so I'll just I'll just say dick
ah ha ha ha I said dick yeah oh I said
poop poop yeah that's funny this movie
has all that type of humor but the way
that the film's characters are the fact
that you like those characters so much
in this movie even though the characters
are technically themselves or versions
of themselves it works because of that
but I really think that if you go into
this is the end expecting a fun comedy
that you're going to have a good time
but you're also going to be surprised at
all the hidden gems that are in this
movie and it has a good sense of
character to it as well where you can
actually care about the people involved
with it and really enjoy it it's just
one of those non-stop laugh riots that
also turns comedy on its head because
there's comedies are so all over the
place nowadays where so many of them are
the same type of thing it's so great to
see a fresh and original film that other
people are going to be trying to imitate
I guarantee that this is the end is a
good film it only has a few issues to it
really and that is a few jokes that
don't really work a few set pieces
didn't play out for me but for the most
part I love this is the end and I can't
find much wrong with it I'm going to
give it an A - I think
it's a great comedy I think it's one
that you should definitely check out I
really hope you guys enjoy it when you
see it it's come out on June 12th let me
know what you thought of it when you do
see it and as always thanks for watching
and if you like this you can click right
here it gets Tuchman eyes